bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france de londres ou paris
sur quelle politique selon vous pèse
davantage la responsabilité de ce
nouveau drame
je pense que la politique qui est menée
par la grande bretagne depuis des années
et qui consiste à externaliser
sa frontière sur le sol français et une
politique honteuse et parfaitement
hypocrite
pourquoi tout simplement parce que vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs dans le reportage
vous avez depuis le début de l'année
près de 30000 personnes qui ont tenté le
passage du littoral français vers la
grande bretagne sur ce nombre environ la
moitié ont réussi la traversée et
ces personnes ont pu s'enregistrer comme
demandeurs d'asile en grande bretagne et
plus de la moitié ont obtenu le statut
et donc
il n'ya pas lieu
d'instrumentaliser ce tram mais plutôt
de s'interroger sur ce que nous avons à
faire en commun la grande bretagne la
france et l'union européenne parce que
pour le moment il faut bien dire que
nous sommes face à un échec qu'elle est
c'est la porte de sortie de l'union
européenne et se précipite à cette porte
de sortie la plupart des personnes qui
ont été déboutés de l'endroit des îles
dont la plupart des grands pays
d'accueil
européen et donc ça nous interroge il
n'y a pas une solution a prôné s'il y en
avait une ça se saurait
et ça serait relativement simple à faire
non il y a des solutions à rechercher
d'abord évidemment lutter contre les
passeurs je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus
mais non ce n'est pas simplement le
coeur du problème c'est un des problèmes
lutter contre les réseaux de trafic
d'êtres humains
à vos seins toutes les frontières que
c'est soit la frontière espagnole avec
le maroc que ce soit la frontière entre
la pologne et la biélorussie où que ce
soit la frontière entre la france et la
grande bretagne
de coopération aujourd'hui ce sera
d'ailleurs l'un des enjeux de cette
réunion dimanche à calais entre
plusieurs ministres européens en charge
de l'immigration ce renforcement qu'il
juge nécessaire l'accord appelle la
coopération mais européenne pour mieux
lutter contre les passeurs
oui enfin si c'est le seul objectif nous
allons vers 1 seconde et chaque je vais
vous donner un exemple très précis
aujourd'hui la plupart des grands pays
européens d'accueil ne renvoie à
personne vers le régime des talibans en
afghanistan et c'est heureux
seulement vous avez sur le sol européen
un certain nombre de d'afghans qui sont
dégoûtés qui n'ont aucun statut
juridique et qui vivent dans la plus
grande précarité alors que vont décider
les pays européens on continue à les
laisser dans la précarité à les mettre
dans les mains des réseaux de passeurs
ou en invente de manière commune un
statut pour eux sachant qu' on ne les
renvoie pas voilà une question sérieuse
je vais vous en parler je vais imposer
notre de questions sérieuses la grande
bretagne
est partie prenante à la convention de
genève sur le droit des réfugiés et bien
il y à un certain nombre de personnes a
calé sur l'ut orale cas les autres
galicien qui volent déposé une demande
d'asile en grande bretagne parce qu'ils
en parlent la langue parce que ils ont
une communauté présente de l'autre côté
de la manche parce que ils ont de la
famille etc est ce qu'on les laisse est
ce que la grande-bretagne les laisse
déposé une demande d'asile en toute
sécurité est ce que il est possible de
prévoir une voie de migration légale
pour eux voilà des questions sérieux
qu'il faut se poser oui il faut
renforcer la présence européenne aux
frontières
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
pour le renforcement de d'un corps de
gardes-frontières européens
très bien oui il faut lutter contre les
passeurs mais il faut aussi
évaluer les politiques publiques que
nous avons mises en oeuvre depuis trois
quatre ans cinq ans et qui sont un
véritable échec à la reine ainsi que sur
l'ouverture de voies de migration légale
louis darmon bien sûr bien sûr une voie
de migration légale d'ailleurs je
n'invente rien vous savez la migration
légale elle avait été votée par le
parlement britannique en 2016 c'est
simple et voté par la chambre des lords
c'est simple et l'amendement up ce mais
qui permettait à des jeunes jambes de
tellement des mineurs qui avaient de la
famille de l'autre côté de passer en
toute sécurité
et bien voilà une voie de migration
légale et ça a permis à plus de 500
jeunes qui voulaient rejoindre la grande
bretagne de le faire en toute sécurité
c'est quand même mieux que sur un rafiot
en plein air en plein hiver et en
enrichissant les pacs alors non merci
beaucoup on aura l'occasion évidemment
de se pencher à nouveau sur ce thème
avec vous pierre henry président de
grand merci à vous fraternité à bientôt
sur notre antenne